CBS News national security contributor
Michael Morell was acting and deputy
director of the CIA and he joins us now
from Washington good morning Mike
good morning Charlie let me ask you this
how serious is this what is it that
should scare us
about this I think two things one is the
the breadth of it Charlie we have never
seen a cyber attack with this kind of
breadth as Charlie said 150 countries
200,000 users I think the second thing
is the sophistication there was two
pieces to this Charlie one was basic
phishing attacks to get inside networks
that happens every day but the second
piece of this was lateral movements
inside of a network once you're inside
so it spread very very rapidly and and
that is very unusual and very
frightening is the suspicion that this
was a nation-state or non nation-state
actor so I don't think this was a
nation-state Charlie I think this was a
organized crime I think this is
cybercrime I think the fact that they're
demanding ransom in order to free up the
data that they are encrypting I think
that is what underscores that but it's
so so that makes it the largest
cybercrime attack we have ever seen
before
compared to the damage done to other
countries the u.s. came out okay Mike
why do you think that is I think two
reasons one Gail is that our cyber
security is better than any other place
in the world second is that we have
appropriate and up-to-date versions of
Microsoft in other parts of the
countries the versions are very old and
therefore they can't be patched or
number two they're using pirated
versions of Microsoft that's one of the
reasons Russia was hit so hard and in
pirated versions can't be patched either
so I think those two those are the two
reasons why the US wasn't hit as hard
shifting to North Korea and their most
successful missile test to date the
North Koreans say this could carry a
nuclear warhead is this a game-changer
so I'm not sure it's a game-changer Nora
for two reasons one is you have to be
careful of taking the North Koreans at
face value they've made claims both
for in the past that haven't been true I
think though it does underscore that
they're there their missile development
is accelerating it's not slowing and
it's not going to stop they are willing
to sit down and negotiate with us but
they are not willing to give up these
weapons or the missiles okay Micah the
president is about to choose a new FBI
directors or anybody that stands out to
you nobody stands out in particular Gail
I think what's important and I think
this is widely recognized that the
individual chosen has to be has to be
nonpartisan has to be objective has to
be seen as such by both Democrats and
Republicans and and that is the only way
this is going to work all right thank
you Mike Morell it's always good to see